dans cet atelier artisanal on s'active
pour la préparation de petits sablés au
chocolat la particularité de ces biskri
le sucre est remplacée par de la date
sécher c'est pas parce qu'on est sans ce
qu'on est un produit de régime puisqu'en
fait nos produits sont naturellement
secret par les fruits donc donc c'est
pas du tout un projet de régime et c'est
un produit adapté à tous chaque jour
1700 paquets de biscuits sont produits
ici une aventure familiale qui a
commencé en 2018
quand gaël a dû supprimer totalement les
sucres rapides de son alimentation pour
des problèmes de santé depuis la start
up a grandi et leurs tablettes de
chocolat lancé il ya six mois a été
primé deux fois on a créé le premier
chocolat sans sucre ajouté sans
édulcorants et là maintenant on peut
déguster un vrai bon chocolat qui n'est
pas amer parce que notre chocolat en
fait et bintou barre c'est à dire qu'on
transforme directement les fèves en
tablette de chocolat ça permet vraiment
de maîtriser tous les process et
d'éviter justement cette amertume qui
peut être trop forte avec une
torréfaction trop 30 ans des produits
commercialisés pour l'instant dans une
trentaine de points de vente en circuits
courts comme celui ci et qui répondent à
une vraie demande
finalement on a beaucoup de clients ou
des petits problèmes de de sucre
finalement et c'est vrai que c'est un
produit qui est quelqu'un qui marche
bien et ça concerne beaucoup ma
clientèle s'est jamais entre le
madagascar et l'autre alors tant qu'à
prendre du chocolat aux 32 des locaux
quoi et puis en plus il est super bon
prochain objectif de la start-up voir
leurs produits arrivée dans la grande
distribution